british forces at kabul airport
processing those lucky enough to have a
ticket out
there are 4 000 british nationals
eligible for evacuation from afghanistan
but fewer than a quarter of those are
back so far the operation to airlift
them along with eligible afghan
nationals depends on the military
section of kabul airport remaining
secure
operation pitting involves around 600
british troops who've been sent to
afghanistan to get british nationals
back as well as afghan interpreters and
other staff working for the uk many of
them arriving back here at bryce norton
in a process the government says it
hopes will be completed by the end of
the month if not sooner
but the defense secretary earlier made a
stark admission about some support staff
it's a really deep part of regret for me
some people won't get back
some people won't get back and um we
will have to
do our best and third countries to
process those people
british afghans are watching this
nightmare unfold on tv and social media
zora from west london is on facetime to
her sister-in-law sophia who fled her
home in kabul
a lot of gunfire and even today in the
morning taliban came to ask my
brother-in-law because he's a police
officer
and
they were asking where he is
zoe is relieved that her brother-in-law
wasn't in today they have been going
door-to-door to
search lawyers journalists
police and
all the people that would basically
better the country or they have a voice
yeah to get rid of them yeah you think
they're trying to get yeah yeah i think
they'll kill them oh yeah of course
that's what they've done before
sophia told me she was two weeks away
from finishing a law degree she might
now never finish
i'm studying political science and i'm
very worried about my future because
they won't allow me to study they won't
allow us to go outside of the home and
we're very scared
western politicians say the taliban have
made commitments but does anyone believe
them we're using our g7 presidency to
make very clear to the taliban that we
will hold them to account for their
commitment and never to allow
afghanistan to be used as a base for
terror
to hold a more inclusive government and
to protect the most essential human
rights including respecting the rights
of women
so many relatives of british nationals
are trying to get out rahim's cousin
tried to escape last night
he was in the airport he had to climb
over the fence to get into the airport
so you could get saved but then they
started shooting and
everyone had to flee
kadria says this weekend her father gave
a bleak assessment of his situation
yesterday when i
talked to my dad my dad said
maybe i don't see you again
for me it was really hard to hear that
it's devastated this catastrophe isn't
just over there
it's felt by many here i want to see my
dad again